[ __ ] that's mine stupid over there
a lot of people are just doing the
jubilee videos
i know they're just doing it on their
own channels
yeah pretty much yeah
but jubilee took
those ideas from like korea another way
they took a lot of [ __ ] we should do
that ourselves we should just line up
some [ __ ] that we know that are funny
and then just do a lot of these videos
ourselves and see what happens what do
you guys think in the comments below do
you guys want to see us at other people
maybe working on andrew schultz some
other folks that we know in the space
expressions oozing some of our favorite
youtubers we're going to call it i
believe
sorry
sorry [ __ ] up offer excuse me
drupal reach
that definitely sounds like our drag
names
um
miss ability and miss prince
i don't know who this miss abba in this
preaching
yes i saw the video of miss abba and
miss preach or whatever the name is
[Laughter]
himself yeah
and um i'm here to i'm here to win some
money
hi my name is danny i'm a twitch
streamer and a photographer these guys
all look like they belong on tick-tock
they all got the same like they all dyed
their hair the same way
um jc i'm
this guy's friend
it's true uh how's it going i'm david
alvarez and i'm this guy's enemy oh not
that we're not that close
hey
i'm reggie weber and if these guys think
that they're beating me then they're all
actors i guess
damn shut that [ __ ] off
[ __ ] if you don't get the [ __ ] out of
here i told you i don't pre-wash this
i feel like this is such a mistake hey i
feel like fighting right now if if i was
jubilee i'd be pissed
no lie i mean because if you're gonna
rip that thing off first at least make
it your own like do your own spin all
right do it add a little flavor no you
took everything you took the same fonts
the same everything now you're just
trying too much to be like that the
editor is not the same hey man the
editor is not the same the difference
with jubilee is that the editor they
know what to take i don't think it's
that i think the good thing about
jubilee is they get regular people who
are not trying to be all extra
and so the people come on and they come
on with a good intention i'm watching
these guys it's like bro y'all look like
you come from the beverly hills but you
try to look interesting it's like yeah
you know i mean like but the reason why
you could probably take all the struggle
in this video and put it in a cup and
it'd still be empty
yeah that's what it looks like it's just
like it's okay the reason it's okay if
you blame you know what i'm saying
there's nothing wrong with it you know
what i'm saying
that's so good but when people try to be
something not then it looks funny and
you can feel that you feel they're
faking the funk yeah when you trying to
jazz something up that shouldn't be
jazzing yeah it's like putting raisins
and [ __ ] salads stop yeah stop that's
facts trying too hard raisins shouldn't
exist i'm mad
why would you take something that's
delicious and then remove the juices to
to to take that's like having a dry
[ __ ] it's a it's not who it is you
could have stay lubricated [ __ ] on the
go i take that chew on that for a couple
of hours what
side of [ __ ]
ah
this is he just really wanted to do that
noise again no i didn't just come back
to me but but no no no it's just not in
salad it doesn't fit you know what
california you ruin everything okay once
you're trying to be like uh i'm gonna
take a salad a california salad i'm
gonna put uh citrus and cranberries in
you ruin that [ __ ] [ __ ] okay you know
the difference between knowledge and
wisdom knowledge is knowing a [ __ ]
tomato is a fruit wisdom is not putting
it in a [ __ ] fruit salad okay stop
ruining [ __ ] california can i just say
that was a bar that may have been one of
your best bars this year that was that
was about that was like it might not be
my bar i said that too it was too too
maybe i've seen that somewhere else okay
i'm not gonna take full credit for the
bar okay but [ __ ] california stop
[ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah let's fax
okay you [ __ ] up sushi oh you know
what would be nice let's put mango no
[ __ ]
we got soy sauce in wasabi
why am i mad like that i don't know what
happened i think your rage is carrying
on and i'm in a happier place
every time i get mad you get you get you
you get happy because they enjoy it and
i know it's money all right i'll be last
i'll take glass i'll take last fight me
for it people say i look like you bro i
don't want to be over there danny if you
look like me that's what people say look
it's the hair look look look look it's
there point with one finger
i think this is going to be the energy
of the whole video i'm just going to be
pissed off for no reason until you click
shut that [ __ ] off dudes were super
cringe i'm wondering if the women are
just as cringe because the dudes seem
focused on like trying to be interesting
because that's the only thing they've
ever done channel a super channel okay
okay um my name is kristen the most
attractive thing about me is
my ability to make people feel
comfortable in every situation well [ __ ]
azmin i think that what is most
attractive about me is
my heart
i feel like i have a big heart and a lot
of love to get
if you don't get the [ __ ] out of here
bro
hi everyone i'm jill
um i think i'm
i empathize with a lot of people and i
like how i can make everyone feel feel
comfortable and safe and vulnerable so i
find that really attractive and i'm
proud of that about myself
hi i'm tara and i think the most
attractive thing about me is that i'm
really fun to be around i think i can
make a lot of people laugh and have a
good time hi i'm mia i'm an accountant
and i think the most attractive thing
about me is seeing people for who they
are and not getting attracted to you
know what i think i think if the first
[ __ ] would have come up and be like yo
my eyes then everybody else would have
said something physical but none of them
want to seem like the cocky [ __ ] so
they're all being super fake about it
that's what i'm gathering yeah because
it's attractiveness and then all they
can talk about is personality
personality but let's keep it a stack
the reasons you'd approach you has
nothing to do with that and it's not the
reason you got casted because i don't
see none of y'all that are like a three
out of ten
so clearly the casting of this is very
right but again this whole society
especially in the west is like we all
put such an emphasis on our looks that's
why we do the most amount of surgeries
that's why we do the most amount of like
photoshop and all this other [ __ ]
when it comes to our looks but then we
never want to say we're leading with
that under my heart
i'm such a bubbly person
meanwhile you got like three injections
and [ __ ] your ass and a bbl done it's
like okay
sure whatever you say clearly you were
willing to put your life at risk to make
yourself more physically attractive but
your heart is with strong people [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here
you're beautiful i'm sorry no i think
you're beautiful chelsea
no chelsea we all know that you're a
model squeeze in chelsea i didn't do my
nails so i feel like i should be in the
back i never do mine
wait no no
no you went from my heart and then no
then cameras were off oh now this that
no which proves your point no
no
[ __ ] no no
but bring no everyone back hey guys guys
we're panicking
we're like what do you want from us i'm
comfortable with chelsea being number
one me too i'm not i think yeah we're
all coming i think chelsea is literally
one of those beautiful people i've ever
seen i agree i agree
okay
now
it's just
you know what it is i need to calm down
you know what it is i know hey bro don't
worry i'm down you're getting better
you're getting better i'll come down
you're getting better
you'll be so stupid
we all that's why i appreciate and this
is why i said this right i've watched a
few videos where women have come on to
the to the stage and they're like i'm
drop dead gorgeous i'm like yes [ __ ]
own that
own that i remember we watched a cut
video and a black woman came on she said
look at this i got no problem i'll never
call a woman a bad name for coming out
and saying that [ __ ] why because we know
what it is we know what we're looking
for so i hate it when they come out here
and do the whole [ __ ] dance we're
like
i'm such a king person
i'm a libra
and all their pictures is a titty's
popping out the turtleneck as dave
chappelle would say
we know what it is
so i appreciate people when they're
forward and they're not doing the
[ __ ] dance and the thing is these
women didn't even keep it up for more
than a minute they started talking about
personality personality personality all
right it's time to rank these [ __ ]
you're so [ __ ] gorgeous [ __ ] i love
you and i want to kiss your lips what
happened to her big heart
what are you trying to kiss your way to
her heart go through her mouth what the
[ __ ] is happening you know what it is
this is exactly like [ __ ] yoga on
instagram okay this is what it is okay
ah prosperity and this and that and the
only pose that you do is
is
the bar no that's the bar
that word dog is [ __ ] up yes you put
that on the please put that on the
shoulder son rise they're more like dick
rising yeah what i'm saying because we
know what it is yo but that's exactly it
are you you you you want to pro problem
that namaste [ __ ] that's fine but when
we look at your profile it's all it's
all you know you know what you're doing
you know what you're doing right
you're showing your flexibility but what
missy is a big camel yeah here
we're not in the desert but we do see
the camera hey listen
yes yes can we put rock paper scissors
rock paper scissors let's just just rock
we want to do the whole way we should do
like oh i love it best of three winner
moves to the back i love it wait you
know i said the dudes were lame but you
guys are [ __ ] lame too
if you're gonna do a jubilee video do it
right or add your little something
something to it that was just a bunch of
people talking about you know what maybe
i'm just not right for western culture
because you got everybody in the
comments being like this is so wholesome
this is so nice
and i'm just looking like where
everybody values this whole fake
niceness that everybody does yeah and
i'm just so over it like i just don't
care for i sometimes i have i'm talking
women she's like i don't want to say
anything that might hurt your feelings
i'm like listen i just need you to tell
me the truth if it hurts it hurts
whatever it is just say it right if you
think my office trash just say that i
don't if i ask you for advice tell the
truth this i can't just ugh it's this
fake niceness
where you're just sitting there thinking
like
do y'all even like each other because
you guys have said a hundred nice things
but not a single of them seems true bro
bro
fake niceness is not about you
okay it's hurting it's not hurting your
feeling so i could feel better you know
i mean so i don't feel like a bad person
it's not about you it's not yeah it's to
hurt your feelings it's not to hurt your
feelings but it's not to hurt your
feelings so that i don't feel bad
afterwards that's what fake nights is
this bruh no i mean they did they don't
oh my god you're so busy through that i
feel good i was nice to a [ __ ] today
but it ain't what it is i was nice on
[ __ ] today so uh yeah i'm a nice
no it's fake it's not nice i think
that's why these are the type of people
who love rap music so much
they are so used to being in their
bubble and their fakeness that they hear
something that seems raw
right or just like visceral oh yeah and
they becoming trans they become the
biggest fans that's why you go to a rap
concert and it's filled with people like
this
right who literally don't identify with
it any type of way but i think it speaks
to some deeper part of them you know
what i'm saying because in their daily
life they don't get to live that any way
shape or form but they don't see it
right
that
that's
that's what that's what's going on
that's a good idea it's like
what are you listening to not bad you're
a takashi why uh i don't know it's just
there's something about his energy
yeah it's it's the it's the crystals
right [ __ ] corny brother i don't i
don't get it i don't get it um it's not
i don't get it i just don't like it you
just got it right now i just don't like
it yeah i just don't like it and i used
to see it all the time online dating and
those are the profiles that basic basic
makes you look good but i can already
tell like your personality's blamed as
[ __ ]
and you know what i do i love it when a
woman's bland and knows it and owns it
that's my favorite [ __ ] so i don't do it
[ __ ] i don't really got much going on
i don't like going out i like that to me
you know it
i like that but this whole thing you
know
fake interesting or fake nice i just
can't rock you know the reason why you
like it why because self-awareness is
really attractive
it's because if you're that honest about
yourself and that's self-critical
then i know you're gonna be honest about
other things i know
that's what it comes down to but anyways
i can't watch the rest of this video
because uh no it's garbage so the
casting and you know what this is
evidence that jubilee is really good at
their job because they cast way better
way better and the content is actually
it gets you